okay hello everyone
it is 154 p.m. and the title arena
starts in just about 6 minutes if I just
quickly glance it who's playing there's
a lot of players it's over 200 players
Carlsen is likely playing except last
tournament he signed up as dr. drunken
Steen and then he switched at the last
minute to an anonymous account so that
was that was sneaky but okay I'm playing
on my own account let's see I am am I
can't talk it's been so long since I
streamed only a few days though I'm seed
49 so I'm top 50 can make a splash hello
to people in the chat hello to eat
Urbanski and zaga djenka oh now i'm seed
50 hopefully i'll stay top 50 and the
goal for the the tournament is to finish
in the top let's say 30 that's a
reasonable goal but the ultimate goal is
to play Carlsen I don't care about
beating him I just want to play him like
one game never played him in chess
before that I know of so as as the time
ticks down here I'm gonna just play a
few warm-up games I want to make sure
that I can use them the mouse in a
decent fashion so we'll go to the
warm-up arena
well how almost three thousand people
playing this warm-up here you know there
is money on the line 50 50 bucks for
first place so I already played a couple
game so far I just want to make sure
that there's no lag okay ooh there's a
little bit of lag it's not too bad okay
now it's fine hey it's a cheer from grey
header
welcome back right header haven't seen
you in a while
I'm liking my position uh-oh lose a beat
palm doesn't matter I really have this
smooth just want a castle finish
developments ooh he's attacking two
things okay let's take the bishop and
play Bishop b3 mm Queen before I better
not lose this I'm playing a 1651 this is
a little bit scary but at least I'm
alive the c7 is gonna fall I'll play h3
at some points if he lets me this is
really scary it's not even Halloween yet
okay after the fan let's play rook a f1
see seven is still hanging also he's
gonna flag I meant to take that's not a
bad move though
wait this is still kind of scary let's
do this
cause it really I felt so slower there
but at least okay I didn't lose that's
not the most comforting warmup
given that I'm gonna play much higher
rated players in the coming tournaments
however I see more people in the chat
Kluth is here I was seeing Shaq yeah I
just got an oil change and as I had to
walk like a mile to pick up the car and
I was as I was walking I was watching
the shack match and they kept making
like shack puns like this was so
shocking and he was so shaky but yeah he
seems not to be in the best form and
gary seemed to be playing well anton
zero thanks for the follow hello to
everyone of origin twitch my wrongs or
mister ons let me know if everything
looks ok i am zero beers deep I'm only
just beginning my tea hopefully by the
end of this stream or about end of the
tournament I'll finish my tea so let's
go back to the arena
oh there's 30 seconds left oh wow good
timing
all U is a little low okay I mean sound
and there's a little bit of lag with the
video too
okay I just turned my levels like almost
a hundred percent hopefully that's
better
deep breath I'm gonna try and win
Colorado see how it goes the ice thanks
for the bits don't cheer too much while
I play so they'll be distracting but
okay I'm playing a GM let's play the
Budapest
okay he's pre moving too quickly maybe I
can take on the c3 nevermind I'll keep
the bishop yeah I've induced before to
play a 5 put the knight on e5 and just
want to be solid
let's take okay maybe I'll attack and
somehow mm-hmm maybe not
each no I don't know what to do just
have to move around
okay Knight f3 and queen g4 looks nice
or queen h3 and IG for ideas III is
attacked too let's double up mm let's
see a breakthrough that was a terrible
move playing - slowly - but okay it's
still a fight put the Queen on g6 I want
to take on that 493 I can play rookie 4
mm tricky and just up a pawn now just
put the rook on the H file well I put
the Bishop on c5 block the rooks put the
rook on d6 up some nice time it's not
hang a rook
oh he hung the rook there okay now it's
usually winning okay that was a good
starts felt like a little bit of lag but
nothing too bad last time I screamed I
actually streamed from the st. Louis
chess club to which account and I had a
really bad performance this was last
month so I'm gonna try and stay calm
this guy is falling into or maybe not I
was about to fall into a trap but he
avoided it the bishop on d3 my knight
will drop back and I'll castle just play
a normal position I'm just trying to be
solid I'll attack the d6 pawn go for
Knight c4 nevermind my knight wants to
stay there
thanks for the bits dead man Indiana
okay I'm gonna double rooks maybe looks
okay let's take
ctrl-f for maybe 94 coming c4 looks nice
so I want my queen to lead the battery
so the plan is Bishop to b1 and Queen c2
let's take the Knights maybe I should
have taken my bishop he can take there
I've made the same mistake twice already
both games allowing bishop take Knights
oh I had queen no I don't have Queen d2
oh let's do this
mmm that's for maybe mu free pawn that's
for coming
I'm up so much time how am I so fast it
was not getting needed
okay a couple of dirty flags but good
starts I'm seventh place two wins in a
row
old player with a sub thanks cold player
appreciate that I feel like the lag is
getting worse
okay now I'm playing a twenty seven
hundred play another London similar
opening yeah I'm gonna be calm very
similar positions so far let me go for
d5 let's play d5 in ninety two and go
for 94 yeah it's all about slow playing
Queen I five is a nice move
mmm that's annoying Cal move back
oh he chops the bishop or does he maybe
he doesn't oh that's this hanging though
blunder okay I'm fighting back though
cuz this is weak
never mind that falls mm let's pin him
AFF for an end
oh he has Queen d4 good move
I'm still fighting cuz it's weird
somewhat weird position go for this
hmm yeah this is looking really bad hey
I'm in somani
just in time for me to get mated also
the video is lagging like crazy let me
switch the webcam properties because I
think it's uh I think it was a built-in
webcam like slowing down the computer
now it looks to be okay
also on Fuji thanks for the sub okay I'm
playing okay I'm playing a beatable
player 2300 play at Budapest okay let's
take the pawn let's play a 5 and Bishop
b4
okay Knight age 3 is a common idea I
play Knight g6 to stop Knight f4 ok he's
moving very slowly Bishop c5
mmm it's kind of annoying let's play
this I'll go for a queen trade I just
want some long ending where I can flag
him
I think g5 might come yeah good time to
trade Queens
oh I'd lend her the piece though haha
that's annoying
I'll have d6 and Bishop take h3 maybe
ooh yeah this looks playable because I
have night each for coming mm-maybe
rookie 5 going for meat still going for
meats
Ice Queen defends good move but he has
12 seconds left I'm gonna flag him I
want to play Knight G 3 2 he's gonna
play Queen G 2 or that
mmm justtake should be an easy flag
let's do this okay
well the people are flagging maybe
people are just nervous they're not calm
they don't have tea like me just coach I
am a good luck
another Budapest another person doesn't
realize I played the Budapest few plays
before can I take on f2 never mind
Camello thanks for the hundred bits okay
so we have another Budapest position
this is like the third Budapest this
tournament let's just keep improving c6
undermined his bishop he's gonna play
Bishop c3 or hold win the a5 fun or not
sway this July plunger again I keep
blundering oh no my Knights or my Queens
defended by the Knights that's nice hey
thanks for the sub whoever you are I can
do this as III spawn is gonna be
weakened and unless he plays f4 good
move f6 this is a confusing position
defend my rook threatening to take now
his pawn was just weak and pinned
let's take with this let's do this
and this stop his rook from coming in
he's still gonna come in though I also
want to come in oh he's gonna win the
pawn and defend his pawn or not okay now
we have another confusing position but
I'm up on time let's play b5
past ponds must be created and then they
must be pushed this is really scary
though he can't push his pawn though cuz
he's pinned what's going on here that's
a good sign there's no idea what's going
on here
he's gonna flag though unless he meets
me Oh
what is going on now this is winning any
fact okay that was nice I only have one
loss and I don't see my name it's a
magic trick I disappeared where am I
oh there I am 33 tea or warm or worm
there's no worms in my tea great chess
coach I'm playing a lot of coaches guess
that makes sense all the title players
hey thanks for the sub Greg Umi or is it
Greg hoon it's kind of annoying I'm
gonna give up the bishop and just focus
on developments and have an open F file
yeah a for preventing b5 King h1 typical
move rook e1 defend the pawn maybe a
Bishop b3 I'll kind of slow play it I
have to defend the pawn
maybe um g5 I want to close the position
because Knights like close positions and
he has two bishops mmm this is confusing
now ah he wins that I have Knight b6 and
also e4 is coming that was a good move
I'll put the bishop on c4 and then
probably to d3 he might win b2 someday
or not Knight c4 will Connor hitting his
queen in both pawns I really want to
take on f6 but I should be patient
hmm 93 maybe I'll get some King side
attack a knife out 5 rook takes f6 is
the threat it's hard to stop - thank you
very much mmm let's move back safety
first
knife f5 is actually a really strong
move because everything now Falls the
Knights coming to e6
unless it's not yes it is ok that was a
nice game and I played quickly enough to
only 1 loss this is my best starts
probably ever 24th place still pretty
early I don't see you Carlson here
Carlsen might be playing on a anonymous
accounts so maybe I've already played
Carlsen but who knows
that's why h3 what is this I can take I
just want a simple position
it's Castle I gave him the bishop pair
but at least I can develop normally a
three I'm Queen up three let's do this
in c3 maybe I can take because I have
Queen take oh no I don't have Queen take
g7 this is a knight defense as a bad
move I still have this so I'm still
gonna be having compensation night h5 is
coming maybe that turned out to be a
good move
where's my plate oh I can take and then
take this is the original tactic I
wanted
hey it's bits again sir doodle pants
thanks very much
okay so now I'm just up a pawn or two or
three oh I lost a piece but he didn't
see it that's good
he had her take off for I'm losing a
pawn that's okay cuz I have a knight
nights are better than bishops and
bullets he's playing well but he's
playing slow oh I lost a knight how did
that happen
but he's gonna flag maybe he better flag
or I'm gonna Queen let's do this
how is rook is tracked oh okay
top ten let's do it I think inventing
inventing is Karlsson it just sounds
like something Carlson would invent not
the best opening so far but Queen a5 or
Queen b6 maybe I'll play d6
or h6
some weird stuff happening what is going
on here
Queens see five looks nice I just want
to go for a King side attack or a queen
side attack against his King
my Queens about trapped but not quite
doesn't have rook a5 but what do I do
b5 maybe please play 92 whoa
that's made in one you wanted Queen take
b5 and I take d6 that was a nice gift
that was a decently strong player to a
seventh place magic and E another London
Queen's Indian
yeah the night ft2 is a funny move but
it's a good move now we get some
position
let's take take and then maybe hope mmm
let's play this first tack this pawn
maybe hold wonder efore or Bishop b5
looks strong and rook c1 I think he's
losing a piece I should take g2 is
nothing just resign you might actually
resign it's taking so long just
realizing his doom yes okay I'm in third
place that's nice
it's all about staying calm and drinking
tea Leon
leave ouch okay good luck Budapest again
okay now we're going into crazy line oh
I shouldn't have played to u6 but it'll
still be interesting yeah it's take and
do this and if you takes I play Queen f6
yeah it's still interesting yeah that's
castle just focus on development he has
triple pawns but a pawn on c7 is very
annoying maybe I can do this an attack
c4 and maybe win back up on he plays
Bishop g2 maybe Queen take up three that
would have been fun okay so I'm down two
pawns but he has doubled pawns which
someday I'll try and win giving them an
option there so now I'm just down one
pawn and I'm up a ton of time that's not
should I trade Queens good no let's not
trade Queens maybe I should have trade
traded Queens
okay yeah he's moving quickly now he
knows he's slow a five let's do it
I want to meet him someday with f6 that
might be difficult though three pawn not
quite ooh free rook can't complain with
that
it's a dirty flag but I'll take it I'm
in second place how is this real life
I'm so calm that's why I play good chess
when I'm calm and I'm not talking to the
chats okay Cambridge Springs okay send
me Slav I don't know what this opening
is mmm splayed Bishop's you six and I'll
take some day let's play b5 mmm Castle
and maybe e5 rookie in E 5 coming maybe
a Bishop b7 I'll be patient
Queen b8 he is so patient 2 or both so
patient who's more patient
I don't mind my position let's take and
play here maybe you went up on maybe not
yeah that didn't turn out so well I want
to play Bishop a6 because this is a
terrible Bishop now that fate you can
never get me that within nine on our
fates and then I want to play I'm Queen
a six maybe mmm this is already kind of
annoying
yeah g6 not a fun looking move
I'm just gonna hobble up and oh he hung
in lights but I didn't see it I trusted
him let's play g5 to keep the diagonal
closed there's so much pressure and I'm
down on time he's gonna play Queen c2 or
not I don't know what to do I feel like
I'm in zoogs long yeah Queen c2 I'm down
so much time I need to do something even
if it's bad
this was really bad yeah it's my second
loss of the tournament in 25 minutes in
I'm still a good start I'm in third
place still I know I'm playing Rebecca
Harris also known as narrowed its key
and play my perk line slay Bishop III
what is this line can I take probably
not good but I'm going for it
f3 up up on let's play g4 I'm a little
bit suspicious about this position but I
am up upon let's play h6
now I like this position now I really
like this position okay he socked to
exchange and go for that and this maybe
take on let's take your first Oh what
does that move I forgot about that move
that was really unfortunate it's still
complicated though draw f6
okay he's over pushing I'm so slow got
to speed it up
this is so bad I had such a good
position - don't tilt stick home
mmm
mmm that was bad such a good position to
Gotham just in the chat let's not look
at the chat it's just stay calm
fourth place still but two in a row
losing that's tough
okay now we have a London it's not a bad
line let's play F 3 and E 4 if you plays
d5 I played G 4
ok this is looking nice play 8 3 play
positional Bishop g5 you can't play h6
because pawns can't move backwards that
was a good move I still want to get a
Knight to f6 ok let's see if he sees my
threats he saw it or he didn't see it
but he defended it I want to take on g6
this is my threats yes I only want a
pawn now do I could have 1 d6 mm-hmm ok
stay calm oh my gosh my queen is trapped
no let's sack
Queen g1 coming no so bad
he hung g6 and I had d6 in my hands I'm
still top ten but Carlson just passed me
that's unfortunate
I'm pretty sure that's Carlson Queen c7
he knows theory yeah I will trade
it's a playable position Bishop goes
back to e2 when goes to a4 and we'll
play some chess
maybe Queen a3
rookie one put the Queen on each for
yeah I can't complain
slight time advantage couple double
pawns but it's still okay
let's play off three and then let's move
this should just be a draw but maybe
he'll grind it down
ooh that's bad okay that's good
so you gonna meet himself he's in
zugzwang by the way and he's about to
[ __ ] I'm so fast
so I'm ninth place inventing inventing
Oh from India though and I am so that's
not Karlsson
where's carlson hmm maybe it's just a
fake country not that I'm calling India
a fake country but maybe he's just
tricking people
okay I'm going for the hack attack
mmm he knows what he's doing now that I
kind of know what I'm doing
his Knights attacked and his pawns
attacked it's not a freak on I'll take
it after seven is kind of weak mmm let's
do this down the exchange but I have
some comp Queen h4 mmm bishop somewhere
I don't know what to do though I'll be
not here
c6 keeps stopping my plans and I'm low
on time
see five is gonna fall or not I'm
stacking upon to get my Bishop to g7
okay you just hung a rook I was annoying
I usually don't get upset but that was
upsetting 30 points 13th place I'm
playing a steno okay let's go Sena
losing a pawn not like it's a center
cohn or anything
maybe e5 is a good move
I allowed Knight f5 still okay mmm I
know how tricky I want to be this is bad
already
I'm alive though barely mm sort of
barely this is weird now I might be even
better here no nevermind let's do this
and then here I'm just down two pawns
and I have a terrible position but I'm
not dead yet
opposite color bishops always save the
day except when I say always doesn't
mean always what am i doing mmm do this
okay
ah this is bad deep breath no tilt let's
play normal chess yeah this is my pet
line Black has a little less space but
it's very playable looking trim can
trade more take and play Queen eye fades
or Queen Yeats
this night as misplace now now my night
is very well placed let's play this hmm
Queen a 5 g 6 let's do this
take take take f6 maybe it was a very
confusing position his night his traps
though if he takes I skewer him on b4
his desperation no Queen b3 that's good
and he's searching desperately for
counterplay but now I'm getting
counterplay and a fork okay this is easy
win
okay back on track kind of 14th place so
who's Carlson if anyone can tell me in
the chats after this game that would be
nice
let's play Knight f3 hey some bits Thank
You Ricardo for the bits my h5 I think
is good in this position because 95
right I did a course on this I think I
mentioned this in the course when Bishop
h4 I can take an very fine position mmm
Queen here to this o f6 was hanging oops
okay so he's being greedy
so let's punish him Brooke c1 will come
maybe Queen b7 that was a good move
Queen b7 right away
oh he played kini 7 that was a good move
I should stop complimenting him on his
moves I want to play e4 if you can let
me there we go
not sure if it helped at all my bishop
was hanging Ricardo with a sub thanks
for card Oh what is this what is going
on ah that was annoying
sorry logging this here hello toilet not
again
Carlson is mine wits Haven in car on
mobile really is that real yeah we have
another London I'll go for this line got
already played this guy a few times and
he knows what he's doing right kind of
h6 one is h6
that's what h6 is do I even do here
maybe King f2 wow this is so bad I'm
losing focus which is not good mmm let's
play h5 I'll run the King to a safer
place
let's take with the bishop okay so now I
have some attack
three nights what was that move g7 is
ultimate target hmm do this first
think I can get away with this I have a
rucksack ooh but he did that yeah that's
not good
this is really not good and my time I
resign
that's bad now I'm in 23rd place I was
in third place like a 20 minutes ago
man with Haven okay I'll look out for
him okay so we have this line which he
fight is called for if he lets me play
Bishop g4 I think it's a good move
because I can play this and then I can
play this and he can't play h3 b5 he'll
play he's gonna play 93 and put the
bishop here it's good move I want to
just destabilize his pawns oh I got fort
it's okay minor pieces are better in the
middle game anyway toy that noggin with
a sub a gifted sub just her doodle pants
that's nice let's play this mmm I got
faith I guess when I bring the knight to
c5
and now I want to bring the Queen to h3
I don't know what I'm doing with my life
this is really bad I'm longtime draw no
draw let's play this mmm
let's play this maybe g5
please take my bishop ah this is so
painful
I've one last trick please fall for it
please he's not falling for anything
that's so bad okay
ah chess is tough playing so many good
players in a row 27th place now I've
lost a lot oh my gosh my streak well
lost three in a row then 1 1 then 2 in a
row and 1 1 3 in the row let's not look
at the it's such a good start though
it's tough to ski in donation wow it's a
Gaga Gingka thanks for the dollars okay
let's play this line mmm c5 was not
expecting D take plate b6 in this
what did you maybe this move it's gonna
play Bishop f4 oh this is unpleasant
again let's do this and then maybe I
chopped his Knights or maybe he just
wins the piece I have one trick it's not
really a trick though if he doesn't fall
for it
do I just resign here yeah oh this is
rough this is really rough the turning
point was when I don't know when the
turning point was probably when I lost
in there and it's key so the Gaga Gingka
thanks for subbing gifted by toilet
noggin thanks to the toilet never
thought I'd say that let's play h5 this
is my tilt opening like a plan is to
Castle queenside and move quickly some
bits from the ice I told you guys not to
cheer when I'm playing let's do this and
then any five okay let's take the bishop
maybe this and I don't know what's going
on
okay I just want to trade I just want to
simplify because too many pieces on the
board makes things complicated
please don't have tactics okay good
that's a weird position just trying to
do something that six was probably a
terrible move let's play this and then
wanna play e5
that was probably a really bad move to
so now I'm stuck we still have this and
rook f7 and Bishop e7 rook a king b7
I just want to trade rooks please please
you're down on time okay this is the
best I could have asked for I should
probably go the other way with my king
or not
yeah the thing is I'm a little bit stuck
this claustrophobia
oh shoot he lost a paw or I lost upon oh
that's so bad maybe I can trap his
Bishop those bishops trapped now I just
wait with my thing
now he's gonna escape it's really
unfortunate this is really unfortunate
is he being slow or that's just my lag
no I resign tough ending
I'd rather dropped up on there for no
purpose okay let's try and take a deep
breath and get back on track
regroup favorite opening it's all about
patience
be patience take the pond
let's not get for it you wants to play
out six but they'll play 93 or this when
I'd see five coming that's not a free
pond good move
stay calm b3 is coming or before
that night is really annoying let's just
trade stuff leave the night on the board
for never mind
yeah so my hope is on getting
counterplay here I'm not sure if it's
kind of played but feels like something
all over PA in some lines and d5 is a
backwards pawn this Bishop is passive
that's a free piece that rook was
overworked no okay that's okay he shouts
my bishop ok that was the first win in a
while I forgot what it feels like to win
[Music]
okay over chess
in 97 is not supposed to be the most
accurate move but maybe it's playable
yeah it looks playable
I want to play up three soon or even f4
it's way off for I was a good move that
was another good move I'm sacking the
exchange I just want to keep the
position closed maybe put a rock on c4
or a queen on c4 double attack free pawn
I'll play rook f2 when things get scary
actually does that work I'm gonna have
to
this is a weird position mmm which I
even do H for I'm running out of moves
it's a problem maybe Queen B for soon or
this draw I would take a draw
mmm this is bad this is really bad
oh this is really really bad
wait this is really good what did you do
that for this is bad again no oh that
was annoying hee-hee Mouse slipped when
he had made in one and then I moved too
slowly Rock ooh I'm not deserting you
cuz I need some momentum on my side I'm
sorry but I'm slow like don't get mad at
me I've already messed up the opening
that's okay make things complicated
apply some pressure apply more pressure
when upon Bishop c5 ooh let's play Queen
B for
and I don't know I'm so indecisive maybe
do this oh that Hung's look hangs a
queen okay I better not lose to this guy
really better not lose he deserts me
prevent him from castling
good move as three seconds left I feel
dirty but too bad
am I really in I'm in for in a third
place I keep losing that's why so ok
where is what place is Magnussen does
anyone know oh he's an 11th place Wow
yeah I don't think I played him yet to
work my way back up played this guy
before okay secret prep queen g4 queen
g3 you can take in Castle queenside just
apply some pressure let's trade Queens
Queens scare me
especially in bullets I'll trade more
always play off three going for f4
and see for maybe when the time is right
there's a time right sure king d4 in the
end didn't calculate that okay this is
gonna get messy um III maybe I want to
play this okay this is actually turning
out well want to win the e pawn now Oh
is he gonna play E - please play you -
never mind
and this is a big mess but he just
planted a rook for nothing okay
momentum two in a row last time I went
two in a row is a long time ago I don't
see my name again that's okay
I exist I played Carlsen in the first
game wait really
I will go back in time once the time
machine is invented I actually don't
believe that but maybe it's true do I
win I beat Carlson unknowingly that
would be amazing if that's actually true
but let's not get distracted
okay this position is annoying I want to
put a knight on that five he really
wants to sack on h6 which is why I want
to put a knight on f5 it's a good
defender let's trade rooks mmm trade
Knights more trades of merrier go for
this Bishop d3 rook c2
I have plans mm taken Queen c4 I just
want to trade Queens
this is a fight I don't know who's
better objectively White's probably
maybe g6 maybe not maybe soon znation
chests the longest ever subscriber mmm
what is going on he's being really
annoying let's play this in 95 okay if
he takes or maybe I'm not okay I just
want to open the position so microchips
can come to life mmm this is not
pleasant but maybe it is I don't know
what's going on here
that was a good move I'm stuck hate
being stuck I'm so hopeful
just stalemate me mmm that's unfortunate
do I really be Carlson in the first game
no way but is this actually Carlson I
forget that game I will go back in time
after the stream ends if that actually
happened how did I play him the first
game though she was random he wants to
be sneaky let's do this ooh afore I've
actually studied this exact line this is
a nice little trick let's play H 5 H 4
ok now it's gonna get weird I think I
have mm let's play Queen G for
threatened Queen G hmm what's going on
here I have no idea what's going on here
maybe I'll go for this and then this
confusing position I want to play Knight
g5 and meet him or her I take f4 or 97
what does that move let's do this
okay that's the fork mmm let's just be
solid and aggressive at the same time
tonight h5 and then I'm king d2 rook F
one is nice
that's a pin and then g4 okay so I beat
Carlson and I didn't know I was playing
Carlsen wow that's um well that's an
item off my bucket list
if I knew I was playing Carlsen I would
have been like trembling the whole game
so I usually don't get nervous but yeah
would have made a huge difference if I
knew I was actually playing him let's
play a dirty opening oh he's playing a
dirty opening was a slime Bishop to b4 I
think in a castle he probably knows more
theory than I then I know Queen g5 maybe
straight Queens is this some sort of
it's not even a trap I just blundered I
was unfortunate I'm gonna play on cuz
I'm sneaky sometimes so the first key is
to get counter clay and the second key
is to get more counter play the third
key is to resign it's just dead losing
okay that was unfortunate I'm okay I'm
top 50 started from the mid 50s now I'm
here again
mmm let's play f3 go for this crazy
attack I think I can take and then each
for each five yeah this is fun for
bullet cuz buck sometimes will have
issues defending and it's just a fun
attack
it's queenside castle and go for a 95
unless he does that Bishop c4 I just
want to keep the pressure maybe f4 f5 I
was unexpected
let's not trade Queens yeah neither for
attack the pinned piece let's take the
rook and then just beyond material maybe
he'll hang h7 or not it's still a nice
position though mmm interesting let's do
this yeah this is a serious problem for
him he's gonna take on a 2 and then
somehow lose
wait where is my win that's really
annoying he doesn't have that many
checks so I don't think that maid is
coming King if I was a good try okay
come on us in the chest I'm not really
looking at the chest cuz I can only do
so many things at once
46 place I'm trying to get a streak
since the beginning of the tournament
have another London I'm sorry if I'm
boring people with the London but it's
my cup of tea
speaking of tea I still have a little
bit left some bits from em flair thinks
I'm Clare okay this is gonna get really
interesting so I'm stacking two pawns
and hoping for something good not
something good I could even do well
let's take the rook first no need to be
fancy do this in this I can take on d6
never mind let's play this
can I take on d6 I'm just going for it
oh I should have taken with Queen no
that's okay I have a lot of nice play
I'll have bishops not hanging why am i
giving away all my pieces yeah I lost
some momentum
I still have pressure rook take T force
of threats this is a move what is going
on here it's such a confusing position
he's well on time though okay dirty flag
coming maybe
ah dirty check me coming that hurts
cuz I was just crushing him and then I
just gave away all my pieces and there
was 49 minutes left and I'm in 56 place
I mean it was a good start to the
tournament I've realized this with my
play though sometimes I just run out of
steam but I'm gonna keep fighting and
trying to finish strong so I've had this
opening before quick Queen beards
yeah I don't mind these positions whoa
he's asking for trouble
everything's covered my bishop my pawn
my knight they're all defended kind of
he just dropped a queen that's nice
he got so confused because the position
was so confusing okay
so trying to start a streak again
forty-four points first place is nerd
it's key you're where penguin is oh this
line okay so we have a reverse four
Knights playable opening let's trade b6
c5 it's very positional line I'll play
f5 no no that's a good move but it looks
playable and then this awesome obstacle
our Bishop action rook d6 is coming I'll
try and meet him somehow
maybe this first attack the pawn which
can't be defended forgot about that punk
okay I forgot about that pun - what's
going on
am I about to get meated have a very bad
feeling about this very bad feeling
about this this is really unpleasant
just I'm not losing yet
while I'm winning this it's a free poem
this is so Oh Oh No
it gives me a win because there's a
potential mate with King and Bishop
against two pawns that was beautiful
wow so many topsy-turvy things in the
span of like five seconds I'll take that
though I was completely dead he probably
had made somewhere at some point but
that was okay
42nd place continue with the London
maybe at some point I'll switch to e4
just to mix it up playing this line this
is a bad line when you play d6 but I'm
playing it anyway because it seems like
it should be fun for bullets he wants to
play e5 though it's about just say he
wasn't gonna succeed with that now h6 is
weak
my chief war will come I'll use this and
ooh
forgot about Bishop e6 okay let's play
King f1 King is safe there may be rookie
194 hmm f3 maybe Bishop take h6 coming
or Knight a got 5 coming that looks nice
some bits
thanks for the bits mm let's do this
I'll be down the oh I'm up a queen now
how did that happen
I'm gonna meet him or not I'll win a
rook I turned around really quickly
thank you drew Sampson drew I got your
email but it was really late so I had a
hard time gathering myself to type out
the response but at some points I will
respond I do appreciate the message
let's do this do listen Bishop f5 I
think is a the way to play there is some
annoying pressure here though let's do
this I'm gonna lose up on but I'll have
two bishops or I won't because I'll take
the bishop but he'll have a backward
deep on that's all I want we could trade
Queens so he's up a pawn but his
position isn't that impressive good move
whoopty - good move
I should compliment my moves and not his
moves can take and Bishop f5 good move
I'm gonna win a pawn at some points
maybe you like right now Bishop g4 on
the horizon yeah that was a bad mistake
by him or was it this is really scary
let's take here no let's take here and
then I take then I'll have if King f1i
mm-hmm
what is going on King f1 doesn't work
cuz I'll have Bishop there if this no
this is good for black that was
confusing so now I'm up to two pawns mmm
I should not have a lot of that this is
really embarrassing
he wants to meet me
no I gotta start free moving no that's a
really hard end game to defend less than
ten seconds he owe me in the chat hello
Kiyomi Kiyomi
stayed awake with me until like 2:00
a.m. last night watching my my bullet
downfall okay so oh he's going into my
secret crappy foreign Queen g4 is very
strong here okay so this is playable
kind of great gift coming up I'm gonna
go crazy just hope for the Greek gift he
knows what's happening he's allowing it
this probably doesn't work at all yeah
an eye that's six oh my gosh
okay I'm going all out h5 h6 it's not
gonna work
that's so sad I still have some attack
not really
I resigned this is too depressing okay
I should stop I should stop pre moving
but it's bullets there's a lot of things
I should stop doing and a lot of things
I should start doing but it's a long
tournament and I'm tired and chess is
difficult when you're tired okay so we
have this line some bits waste monster
thanks for the bits this guy knows what
he's doing but I also know what I'm
doing
we're not five I think as a novelty in
this queen of class still playable
expecting Bishop III I'm attacking
Knights his Knights are clumsy
thanks for the subways monster also am i
what is going on here guess he's getting
away with that which is irritating so
now I'm down a pawn and down like ten
seconds on the clock but I'm alive let's
take in 95
did that just rhyme I'm losing a rook
just exchange but now I'm down the
exchange and a lot of pawns this is not
good
I'm playing this out because I have a
rook should never resign when you have
the rook because ideas a self stalemate
so I put my King on each five let him
take my pawns please take the rest of
them that's not quite stalemate yet and
I'm giving it away that's such a dumb
move please play Kings you won I still
have a pass each pawn though
I just want to steal me myself didn't
work okay it's time for some change
there's 37 minutes left I'm in 50th
place I started in like 50 first place
we're gonna play e4 and let's play a
grand prix against the Pierce nice
attacking opening Queen h4 I like this
position Queen g4 it's gonna happen or
that let's play this he's playing
aggressive that was a very strong move
but this is a very strong move we're
such strong players this is annoying
because now he's gonna have that move
but I have Queen take me three always
play King h1 he wants to trap the bishop
okay so now I'm down on time again but
I'm alive let's trade Queens
would like to get the night to e3 and
then d5 I'm in cemani thanks for the
hundred bits this night is kind of stuck
ok I'm unraveling untangling in the
style of Andrew tank and 96 is coming he
can't stop it can cream of that that was
an interesting attempt but now I'm up
the exchange be three solid Oh what to
do maybe this free pawn rookie six never
mind take f7 93 will happen okay that
was a nice game change the pace change
of openings I'm gonna try and mix it up
even more
I just need something fresh something to
wake me up and then probably when this
ends I'll stick around to see what
happened in the game that I played
Carlson he's playing this Gotham chest
line but he meant to play e4 so that
didn't quite work okay let's play
h5 let's play this
playing larsa also is a known me chest
regular from Norway I think I think I
have a pretty good score against
Norwegian players as tournament um okay
there has to be some breakthrough here
maybe just this and attack
I forgot Bishop c3 is playable
I still have pressure not as much
pressure as I would like but okay this
is very strong now so you can't defend
the bishop and the knight is pinned
he's completely stuck I forgot about
that move this is gonna get really messy
but I think my king is safe I hope the
King is safe
Queen f6 Bishop e7
what is this position maybe you work
here or maybe work here have no idea
what's going on
oooh that was physically painful but I'm
still alive
do I have meats what's going on here
mm-hmm what is this position I didn't
know what's happening there is lag and
this team just walked all the way up a
board I was a bad situation to be in
time trouble
51st place
I mean I'm I'm happy like I'm content
with my play given that I played Carlsen
that's all I could ask for
okay now we have a Stafford gambit Ivan
played this yet this tournament Bishop
III he seems well prepared but can you
ever be prepared against this opening
mmm this looks nice yeah this is already
trouble Queen see one coming
ooh he has Queen take f7 so I should
take there in castle or take on d3 take
the Queen undone Castle so now I'm just
up two pawns Bishop d5 will come that
didn't really do much
maybe s5
if he takes like play Bishop c4 whoa
that was a lot of suds that's a ton of
suds dead man DM gifting
how many subsets he he just gift gifted
20 people subs we're gonna hear a lot of
noise for the next like minute or two
that's insane
things dead mandiant let's play this and
maybe this that was a bad move I have to
move much faster and not get distracted
welcome to all the new subs okay let me
focus so much sound that was a really
bad move but I don't didn't see what
else to do this is really unfortunate
he knows how to meet with king and rook
well done to my opponents well the sound
of new subs is slightly comforting but
five losses out of the last six games
that's rough
okay well nearing the last half-hour of
the tournaments well I forgot to play e4
I also forgot to play e3 no other good
start to this game he's gonna play e5
and I don't think it wins the piece
actually it just drops upon its Queen 85
just Bishop c3 I just dropped upon this
is where the chest starts getting really
ugly but somehow it's equal material I'm
not sure how that happened it's got lots
of Clare Bishop position hmm
and let's do he's winning a pawn let's
do this when it's off the court bishops
you don't want to hang your queen I was
about to give some great life advice not
hanging a queen is good life advice
joana joana is now a sub welcome Joanna
okay so let's do this line and can of
yeah this is what I used to play back in
the olden days
b6 is a blunder though because that
Queen c2 is a double attack and I'm
threatening I'm actually trying Bishop
e4 as well so what does that move they
should take h7 first okay it's still
gonna be tricky
maybe rookie 4 mm let's do this Queen no
Bishop e3 first I also had Bishop f4
there's so many options just have to
trust it intuition let's do this I want
to someday play Queen h3 there's a d4
clever move he's gonna play Queen h6 and
maybe Rock age or up to e3 those rook h3
is hard to stop there we go and double
attack that's a nice oh he has bishop g6
I'll pay h4 just keeping the initiative
it's gonna take on d4 I'll win a pawn
he'll win upon I'll know I don't win
upon let's do this
I bring this rook to h3 now he doesn't
even have rope d8 okay that was nice
I played quickly and he played slowly
and I kept some pressure those nice
opening preparation okay
well the sound of subbing stopped so
thank you for all the subs and thank you
especially to dead man dead man is an
awesome man Bishop g4 the so called
Portuguese variation I think you sixes
of Crossan how the game in this and the
protests League I think i blundered
maybe I blend Red Queen a for there what
is going on what is this position 95
again I've wondered Queen a for but now
I'm safe but maybe not sound let's do
this I want to take here
g5 will come at some points like right
now yeah so now I'm up a piece for three
pawns that's good it's actually a very
good imbalance for bullets I think I can
start winning pawns or maybe it's not
maybe it's other way around the pawns
are better in bullet but I'll still I
should still win this just want to
simplify ooh
forgot about that move hopefully this is
still okay that's a very strange
position no idea what's going on I'm
winning this pawn though I think this
should be winning for black objectively
yeah this should be winning but can I
win quickly enough
yeah it's hard to cream of his white
when you're the queen that's moving like
that usually the best strategy not to go
for meats but to go for the flag
okay well 53rd place 24 minutes left I
kind of want to play Carlson again let's
play e4 trying to remember in honor of
toilet noggin playing the exchange
really well I forgot to play now this is
still a fine line I forgot to Castle
first let's play 92 this will be very
playable I'll just gather a Roy
structure like c3 and king c2 king is
safe and then the goal is to trade
pieces and chop the bishop that was nice
c4 maybe no let's do this
d5 is kind of weak so I want to play
Knight c3 let's trade everything just
stay calm almost out of tea but not
quite want to move the rook back and
then plate rookie 7
this is actually I'm getting a little
bit annoying because I'm losing f3 but
it's okay cuz I have a pass to H pawn
and the doorbell is ringing sorry to
whoever's at the door have to wait yeah
this plants promoting good try or I'll
just win all his pawns plenty of time
okay I should check the door rights let
me pause
there we go
[Music]
okay I think I was too late I have no
idea who was at the door phone is not
going off so I think it's okay so now
I'm playing the guy who I thought was
Carlsen but isn't actually Carlsen he
just fell for the Center for trick night
before no Queen D AIDS okay we have some
position sneaky sneaky Oh
Bishop h5 maybe f5 be aggressive King h8
I think I'm winning material unless I'm
not else I'm meeting him no I'm winning
material this is nice ooh
the knight is captured but it's okay
just have to protect the King and not
hang a bishop
not sneaky am i meeting him I'm meeting
him that's nice
that's really nice well I just kept
attacking then out of nowhere it was
just forcemeat okay I'm on a streak four
games in a row 64 points and I'm playing
Lawrence Trent Lorenz Trent doesn't need
luck this is opening its a playable
position some kind of English it's juice
Sam Soon thank you
maybe I'll play 97 at 600 I hung a
knight where did that figure out that
was hanging so now I have to avoid
trading pieces and also play quickly
this is really uncomfortable if you can
just stop it that would be nice so now
I'm down a rook I'm winning upon
[Music]
now I'm done the exchange I'm losing a
queen I have a night for for Queen never
as I'm when you have a night I resign I
broke the rule I was too painful yeah I
just dropped tonight on g6 it's a nature
of fatigue
okay creative player play another before
Grand Prix attack mmm it's plane 82 yeah
I don't mind this position because we
got a structure where I know where all
the pieces want to go mmm 596 this looks
really risky I'm probably just losing a
pawn yeah I'm I'm winning upon back this
is weird okay I'm just gonna forget
about the Queen side and go after the
Kings side
I'm looking for resources which don't
that they don't exist let's do that this
is so sad
so I'll have an extra queen I still want
to remove the night-sun panel let's play
Bishop here no biggy he's just having
three Queens on the board I still want
to meet him he's attacking my queen I
still want to meet him this is so sad
pawn store him no I have zero seconds -
that was sad I was a lot of Queens I
haven't seen that many queens in a while
45th Place nice drink has ended my few
streaks have all ended pop-quiz what's
the best opening ever I'm gonna play the
best opening ever of this game but I
can't play it against the French so
we're gonna play the best opening
against the French which is whatever
this is some Kings Indian position he's
being sneaky ooh I meant to play h5
that's okay
maybe Roque three coming queen is not
yet trapped let's play this Bishop g2
and c4 unless he plays c4 it's good move
have to sack the exchange get some
closed position bring the bishop back
want to play h5 there we go maybe bring
the Knight to g4 now this is annoying
I think I have to take use up so much
time too
yeah this is a big problem this is a
really big problem he's making another
Queen know why I'm holding things
together not really though preventing
Bishop h4 now I'll break through it's
probably too late or maybe Knox just
have to make my one queen more powerful
than his two queens except you traded
Queens it's really unfortunate
Jessa's tough jess is really tough I
just dropped below 2,500 so now my goal
for the tournament is to stay above
2,500 okay I'm gonna play Queen b3 oh
we're taking a 6 is a great move it's
just so easy to play this for a white
now unless he's able to trade off hey
thanks for the bits or the the donation
tree shape that each three and g4 will
come
yeah I'm winning back material put the
King on c3 that's annoying but they work
here first
that's also annoying
he's gonna win the b3 pawn or not
probably go for b4 and 95 get some
initiative mm oh no maybe I'll for Kim
there we go
hey thanks for the sub tiny something
am I getting mated I'm not getting mated
okay I'm alive I'm gonna win pawns my
king is gonna infiltrate my king will
help out with the meeting attack there
we go
ooh I forgot about that this is a
beautiful mates oh wow
King c8 97 Bishop g4 good try
I was so beautiful it was really
beautiful and now is maybe the only way
to win cuz his pawn can't be stopped
okay forty fifth place I think you
amman's money for the compliments so
that that mate was more beautiful than I
could ever be okay so we have another
Stafford gambit I like when people start
thinking in that position h3 okay so I
was analyzing this other day this gets
really messy I mean white is objectively
better but he has to like there's some
Lion King f3 Queen f6 can take e4 this
line is just better for luck
I can take and ni g3o Queen e1 okay miss
Queen e1 life is good
mmm let's be patients improve the pieces
attack the Bishop 94 coming I don't care
about pawns maybe I do
or maybe I don't I'm takin b5
a little bit uncomfortable but things
are solid still kind of boo this hangs
okay never mind
it's really painful I have together rook
to g6 and win g2 and flag him
three queen three bishop so much lag so
much lag
that's probably my computer my
computer's fault processor is not fast
enough for my speed
also because I'm streaming it just slows
down things when I get in time for time
pressure I've said new game let's play
b5 yeah common trick oh he can take on
c4 though he tricked me back okay so now
we have some position it's playable hey
rook c8 there's only six minutes left
for this tournament bring the knight to
f6 queen goes to b6 bishop goes to a6
rut goes to be AIT's just keep improving
yeah the position isn't that impressive
but Lisa's solid he's moving really
quickly I have a d4 here let's play d4
probably wasn't a good move yeah this is
looking bad and go for Queen c3 and pray
for the best
no this was really bad I don't see how -
okay I can fight maybe they're not
really yeah
Jessa's tough can I try and finish
strong fifty first place
my goal was top 30 I had a very strong
start but that's a fatigue of playing
one minute so tough so the reason why I
played night fd2
was so someday I'll play Knight c3 with
a knight a slightly better place and now
I'm trying to go for a sharp and play
don't know if this is training into
anything I take I'm so bad at counting
when I'm tired but this is a fine
position I have some attack activity C
sevens attacks they work f1
close things down now I want to attack
on the kingside at some point yeah my
king is super safe now I don't think I
want to trade Queens just yet ooh that
was a bad move that was really bad
yeah he's winning pawns Oh
ninety-two don't play it No never
resigned when you have a Knights
my night is so sad never resigned when
you have a rook okay rook activity pass
pong time advantage he's about to me me
I'm about to flag well I want to end the
game okay I'm playing board chess
let's not the zerk cuz I want to end
with a win this is a great at lying
against b3 let's play this this this
I just really like this position it was
very solid I have the g4 square
I was Bishop his bad ah I just want to
create a battery so I can win his
Knights he's played nine each one I did
not mean to play g5 okay thank you
yeah I'm sorry but I don't Buzzard back
and there's one minute left I don't
think I'm gonna have another game unless
I have another game this game won't
count for the tournament but it will
count for my pride and my ego let's play
a Grand Prix attack d4 I think is the
trend these days move
not the most comfortable situation but
at least now I have a solid position
will trade Queens place an endgame or
queenless middle game good move yeah I
feel like I'm getting outplayed let's
put the rook on D too
he's working this in this okay I'm still
not dead my time is bad but now I'm dead
I'm not going to resign because it's the
last game and my king can walk up maybe
maybe not
that's not even stalemates I tried heads
yeah
good technique ok that was a rough
finish that was a good start was a while
ago to our long tournaments 49th place I
would see that 51 by finished losing
rating points Carlsen finished in third
much D Pro I am finishing in first from
oh this guy from Vietnam yeah he's
pretty good at blitz I'm Savin chess
from Armenia who's even chess
since I wasn't interacting Oh Andrea
seein if I said that correctly I met him
and um in California back in March or
April for the protest League a good
player kill me yeah Kiyomi was watching
my bullet games last night I was getting
a forked all over the place and yeah my
last few games least that last game
there's a lot of Forks jarana tries is
now a sub when did that happen maybe
that was part of the sub gifting well
welcome to all the new subs and thanks
to dead man DM thanks to everyone for
the support and watching me in such a
difficult situation in so many difficult
situations a lot of tough fights but
chess is tough it's really hard like
especially with bullet to keep the
momentum and like to stay sharp
I felt really sharp at the beginning
like really calm but then there is that
one moment I don't know if anyone
clipped it's where I almost like I don't
know what I did I got really upset like
probably the most upset I've ever been
on stream which I apologize for if
there's any young people watching if you
lose the game you should always just
stay calm so what to do oh yeah I beat
Magnus Carlsen
how did that happen also Magnus wasn't
streaming I don't think yeah because he
was someone said he was playing on
mobile so how do I find my name here we
go
I play them in the first round - but
where is the game
what was his name man
wait no I didn't play him the first game
who was saying I played him the first
game this is not Carlson do I play him
game one angelic Jake seems confident
people were saying I played him
I played someone else in this with this
name I don't see oh wait why doesn't it
scroll down I see what you mean because
uh their number adheres so that was game
for
maybe leech s only shows the top okay so
what I'll do
wait let me go to Carlson's account and
click his name no so this only shows six
ah so leech s probably has a built in
minutes where it cuts off at a certain
points this is probably a simple coding
issue that can be fixed so that's okay
man with Havana so I'll just go to my
profile and do a search for its this is
a nice tool or no I can just go to his
profile am i doing okay so if I go to
Carlson's profile new name so he did not
play under dr. drunken Steen I guess for
two tournaments on the road now and I go
to his games yeah so we played and I
beat him how did this happen
and up I heard he was playing on mobile
but that was just some random comment I
don't know if that's true but regardless
I mean my I I said before the tournament
my goal is to play Carlsen I did not
have a goal of beating him but I play
them on knowing I'll have to go back and
watch and see see how it happened I beat
him with a Budapest
Oh cuz he pre move Knight c3 wow that's
so great
so because the the first like three
games I was black I played the Budapest
so ok
you played Queen d1 yeah I've had this
position many times before in wood I
might even be like in the opening book
no stronger players and me have played
this too ok so we had some normal
position oh yeah I was happy with this
idea to play Bishop c5 provoked before
and then I can do this break with a5 I
had a lesson yesterday with a student
and I was introducing into this very
climatic break Thank You phenomenon for
the 50 bits so anyway I think I played
a5 at some points cuz ya know this pawn
has to go away and that gives me more
squares to work with can I scroll down a
little oh you want to see the computer
analysis well take a look at computer
analysis after the game because I just
want to look without an engine
especially because it was bullet oh it's
so funny because I like I have very
little memory of what happened next like
if I cover up the notation I don't
really remember how this game transpired
but ok let's see my G 6 ah yeah so he
took with the pawn and then I was really
scared for most of the scheme that the C
pawn was going to come under fire but
that never quite happened
i provoked some weakness with with g3 no
I was just kind of turtling
just holding things together 95 was a
nice move
ah yeah this is a moment where it's
really hard to stop Knight g4 so like
already even from this position there's
some nice play for back you should
probably play Queen s1 no between f1
Knight f3 so I have a feeling like maybe
Bishop d3 is already a mistake and
that's hard to see because this is a
forcing line maybe Queen e2 is a better
move to allow f4 I'm in some money that
was in 50 bits thanks so much
so Queen d1 okay the computer says it's
dubious I guess Queen h3 but I played
Knight g4 and I was feeling really good
here so much pressure rook e8 I'm gonna
change the stream title because this is
no longer that Irina actually no I won't
change this team just the stream title
is um yeah this is still going over
games from the arena I wanted to change
the stream title too I unknowingly beat
Carlsen but maybe that will be the name
of the YouTube video or something
so anyway 9 of 6 to take ah yeah I that
this was just a terrible move on my part
but somehow I stayed alive and it felt
like I was getting outplayed and then
Queens got traded and that made me happy
and Bishop yeah Bishop h6 made me really
happy because this is a point that he
can't really defend his pawn if he moves
I take on e3 and if he moves a knight
I'll have rookie 4 which i think is very
strong so I won the pawn I got the
Bishop to e5
and this is where I was scared of like
rook c1 and b6 or something but he never
went for it maybe he wanted to play b6
so that's why I played b6 I was still
scared of like this and then this and
then ideas of rope take b6 so that's why
I put my Bishop on c5 I have a feeling I
won this game on time and not over the
board but let's zoom forward because now
this is a typical like Carlson grind
down where he just has like a better
endgame oh but I should show the time so
let me make this smaller just a little
bit I have to expand this too because
the times bear with me
yeah the times should show up right
there if people can see on the side
there
yeah so at this point why it had nine
seconds I'd 15 seconds so I was just
playing much faster and let's see how
this happened then he dropped a paw and
then it was just a dirty time scramble
where I was just faster 56 world
champion move and then I won the rook
okay well it wasn't like the most
thrilling oh that was pretty thrilling
so like kind of have a topsy-turvy game
so I think I was better around like
Queen h3 and then I played Knight f6 and
I just slipped and I was better again
well I got my Bishop to e5 and then
somehow he outplayed me and yeah that
was fun
okay
so I have things to do today
but I've knocked an item off my bucket
list
so what to do
oh I've disabled challenges that's why
no one is challenging me I think I'm
gonna end it here I don't really want to
end it because that was just that was
fun but I'm kind of tired it's becoming
increasingly hard to talk Hans I see
your comment but the last thing I need
right now is more chess so Oh what to do
yeah I'm gonna end it there thanks guys
for watching appreciate all the love and
support thanks for all the new subs
thanks dead man GM for gifting 20 people
subs I'll be back in the future I don't
know when though cuz I'm leaving town
again in a few days I'll be in st. Louis
soon and then I'm gonna be busy like
tomorrow is a full day so I don't know
when I'll stream next but I will stream
in the future so there's a couple
streamers let's show Fiona some love the
one and only fee and Chetta let me give
a shout-out to fianchetto too because
she she's one of the only chess players
on the planet which or who is keeping
like a consistent blog or vlog VL OG on
on youtube and the videos are really
well produced I think she has some
outside video editor and she streams
she used to stream more often but it's
good to see she streaming now so I'm
going to go ahead and raid the one and
only fianchetto alright see you guys
wait is she actually live yeah okay
wait that's not her oh that is her okay
alright bye guys